quella tutti ragazzi è pervenuti
avessero video sono fa vj oggi siamo
tornati su facebook e bing che è
veramente figo è uno dei pochissimi
horror piazzati punti è bravo infatti se
gira che ha segregato addosso però mi
diverte un casino lagat a parte il fatto
che ci sono degli altri scenari che sono
tutti i coming soon che non ho capito se
per sbloccarli devo fare prima gli altri
se si sbloccano contempo non lo so la
vedono ancora completato gol e l'altra
volta che è impossibile difficilissimo
però ce la devo fare perché io perché io
cioè i baffi e gli uomini coi baffi ma
c'è piccolino ecco l'aspetto che devo
essere prima nudo
eccomi qua con tutta la mia peluria devo
capire un attimo come avete visto anche
voi ragazzi c'era un tipo quad ma come
velista ragazzi si stanno già portando
perché vi vogliono fare il culo in
realtà lo scopo di sto gioco è quello di
battere i due stronzi quelli che tentano
di ucciderti già provato l'ultima volta
ma è stato alquanto difficile diciamo
non è così semplice come stai imbarazzi
un casino l'importante è che riusciamo a
far fuori si 2 stronza ragazzi mi piazzo
prima così almeno se passa quel
deficiente lo in gruppo di brutto io se
devo essere sincero ragazzi starei ok
sono tizi barbuti che vi guardano da
lontano sti stronzi stalker ti denuncio
voglio prova a fare una trappola della
madonna lega se riesco a far la medagli
a gogò proprio che cadono così una volta
che li do fuoco dovrebbe morire no cane
non passare questo si chiama cane lui ok
la benzina c'è sono nudo e posso dar
fuoco a gaza
porca [ __ ] cane dove vai cane cane
scherzavo cane non volevano non passarmi
sopra la benzina cane che ti picchio la
benzina no
cazzo non ha preso fuoco non ha preso
come non ha preso fano come non detto e
morto cane
e vabbè dai succede più tristezza che
cosa come cazzo hai fatto a prendere
fuoco to mac ma veramente
ma se i [ __ ] non ho capito come ha
fatto ma mi ha preso fuoco la tizia
canemorto hai dato fuoco a una mia amica
lurido per cent a zia tutta nuda
perfetto ok
bisogna essere nudi ragazzi perché se
non si e nudi non si fa quando passa
quel [ __ ] tiro la cor la corda e
cade ricade in testa poi gli passo sopra
quel motorino e poi do fuoco ancora io
non ho capito ragazzi come cazzo è
possibile possa essere merda
ok ok camera a sangue freddo sangue
freddo semifreddo giu
non ci posso credere non ci credo non ci
credo non manca al mancato o non
riuscito a mancarlo il piano andato a
[ __ ] carica [ __ ]
sono morti tutti anch'io credo però va
bene dov'è lurido presente di merda
dargli fuoco dargli fuoco
no ammette ha tirato facciamo una
maschera che ho dato fuoco basta no no
note che ti svaniti riaccendo ecco bravo
ti butto proprio nella merda
ok fermi un attimo si sa ma non era lui
a io stavo facendo fuori il mio compagno
perfetto sono un [ __ ] genio ragazzi
ho fatto fuori tutti i miei compagni al
costo di lui il mio piano è andato a
[ __ ] complimenti fari sei un cazzo di
genio ti stimo sempre di più regalo
perso mediamente ovvero già farò mai a
batterlo da solo come cazzo faccio
ragazzi come cazzo faccio a vincere ad
enel possibile mai nella vita ce la farò
vi fa qualcosa l'estintore 9 melli e li
sfrutto solo acqua in faccia ma come fa
essere lì ma dai non ce la farò mai a
bayonne chi cazzo era questo
o mio dio reca a perm in attivo non gli
ha fatto un cazzo non gli ha fatto un
cazzo di niente lo sapevo io quando non
estintore tutto nel culo tutto ragazzi è
il gioco più difficile che abbia mai
paquette mario è una merda in confronto
giu rosa alzi le mani che se un defilè
se pagato
ok se l'ha pagato all'inizio cane cane
devi darmi una mano non è che posso
perdere sempre però perché pezzente seas
con di qua dietro che lurido siamo
partiti male ce la possiamo fare io lo
so e poi c'è questo
che è una pistola ma funziona funziona o
dato fuoco a cannes e no cane fermati
canek anica no no no no no no no no no
ma perché devo far casino ogni volta ma
[ __ ] mi sono dato fuoco mi sono
dato fuoco
già ora dato poco e ora va da poco sono
morto cane non è morto cannes è ancora
lì che corre come un [ __ ] non dar
fuoco alla germania io non ci ho parole
regate sto riuscendo a uccidermi
completamente da solo ma basta morti
tutti ma come [ __ ] arriva mica
tizio adesso non so perché ciò sto
presentimento incredibile ma guardate
che caso ma guarda un po dopo non avevo
dubbi nella guarda ti investo come se
investissi a tua famiglia grande scala
casalino in motorino di mortacci tua
non si è riuscito anche ad alli fuoco ma
come è ma cazzo non riesco veline anche
fuoco perfetto rega sono morto a
prescindere e vabbè è vero che c'è la
mamma [ __ ] cioè la mamma [ __ ]
niente ragazzi impossibile quindi
ragazzi siamo di nuovo impostazione per
evitare ulteriori problemi direi di fare
una bella cosa
ciao cane addio cane siete pronti a
state per assistere al genocidio se non
funziona sta roba non so cosa fare più
con un'andata adesso la carica la carica
la carica alla carica la carica la
carica è spento carica non è possibile
cazzo lo sapevo che c'era qualcosa che
andava storto cristo ma vaffan coeva
bene ovvio o vieni vieni qua se sei
coraggio vieni vieni vieni vieni vieni
vieni riprendi quello prendi quello vai
corri
dai fuoco si sa se sono morta anch'io
tipo con tutti però va bene portante che
sia morto lui va bene ragazze che cazzo
è successo non vorrei dire tutto questo
perché era solo spento il motorino
solo per questo [ __ ] tanto si
rialza ragazzi lo so che si rialza in ma
non è lui è che due [ __ ] non è morto
ancora dai dai dai collasso a con lascia
come ridotto come fa a vivere
è assurdo come fai perché se una croce
caccia aiuta possibile regala dai col
marte vuoi sfidarmi zio vieni qua basta
via no erano d'altro canto ma perché ma
qual è il tuo problema mentale
maledizione qual è ma no non ho mancato
la mancata affronta sua tappa ho vinto
voi non lo sapete ma in realtà io ho
vinto è una roba invece io non so come
si fa questo merda perché come non è
possibile
sono venti all'ora cane di merda te ne
vai a [ __ ] è indecente sono venti
volte prova la stessa cosa mai una volta
che la pepsi slovacca laida di una
miglior amica si esca falsa cosa prima
di crepare per l'ennesima volta plum
cambio vai vai deve caricare lo aspetta
un attimo che c'è la radio perfetto
ok però è caduto dall altra parte cazzo
dove accadergli i divi no no non dovevi
di christian gesù su su su su su forza
su bravo bravo il no si bye bye bye 32
non un accendino l'accendino ciancimino
[ __ ]
io prendo due dove è andato dove è
andato dove è andato cazzo era lì è dove
dai marco ma dovere
ma da vi prego eccolo spara su kamalov
ed applicazione ti fa male ma quanto mi
sta dispiacendo è morto è morto è morto
è morto
la chitarra [ __ ] chitarra ha bruciato
la chitarra e la pizza è nuda va beh
questo è già un vantaggio
dov'è lo sapevo lo sapevo lo sapevo lo
sapevo lo sapevo è succhia e [ __ ]
sapevo da è deve morire ti la famiglia
in tre modi diversi
devo riuscire in qualche modo a farli
fuori entrambi non so come [ __ ] a
tutti i personaggi quasi per la prima
volta nella vita dove cazzo se se se
ma [ __ ] anni per uccidere sto
[ __ ] non ci poi milano le lacrime
agli occhi anni per uccidere subito mi
incazzo in casa sembra mazza mi incazzo
se mi ammazzano incazzo mi sto
incazzando faida esca faida esca file ex
cave di qua di fork non l'ho preso l'ho
preso doveva ricorre dove cazzo corri
non posso scendere sono intrappolati
questo la pratica ragazzi è morto non è
morto lo so lo 1 gli ho dato fuoco
non so se è morto un os x prego di non
sono mai arrivato a questo punto mai è
la prima volta no veramente sono
emozionato dove è andato quel [ __ ]
dove come hai fatto come cazzo a far
manama come ma non è possibile
la lega come ha fatto è assurdo ma vabbè
regata è se share sono anche caduto giù
guardia sulla sedia
mettiamo ecco che bello risolto tutti i
problemi sono rimasti due senza una
gamba e uno con la faccia anche
triturata mi spiegate come faccia
vincere come ha fatta salva gli ho dato
quale avete visto tutti che io ho dato
fuoco come a fase buttato nell'acqua
forse che correva cazzo non ci ho
pensato
ti va di scendere se governo se c'è un
altro bengala il culo che gli faccio
ragazzi ci prova ci provo non lo so si
ha preso fuoco di no no no no no no no
no no no no 9 cazzo scappi ragazzi no
però è non è che si può buttare in
piscina ogni volta ha dato fuoco a tutto
quello che anche a cane e [ __ ]
ho finito i proiettili [ __ ] la vacca
la bacca siediti da che non ti becca
chi ha beccato lo stesso ma guarda un po
questa roba è notato mi uccide ti sparo
la famiglia è una tua madre è un cesso
prima la uccide e poi ci fai sesso
concluso qui è infatti se qualcuno sa i
peggiori fi non so se più difficile
questo fa united freddy's cane darmi una
risposta o ti uccido
giuro ecco fatto [ __ ] tutti
d'accordo ragazzi concluso primo
episodio è stato un uomo fatto cioè sono
uscito andare avanti tranne uccidere
quel [ __ ] quei baffi ce la farò
prima o poi se comunque qualcuno e dei
consigli perché io non so come cazzo
ucciderla impossibile fatemelo sapere
nei commenti ragazzi o comunque concludo
che l'episodio e quindi ragazzi servite
le è piaciuto se questo strumento mi
piace anche a pasini facebook e come la
navy dotata restizioni sono severi
cityscape e chic di euro prossimo belle
ragazze